with everyone already doing so much
videos how would you not follow Trends
to stand out why don't you just follow
Trends because I don't want to copy I
think a lot of Agents here feel the same
way so let me understand because you
don't want to copy you're just going to
let everybody else get the business
yeah true
okay I have a better idea why don't you
copy and get some of the business but
how would you stand out you are already
standing out because you're a different
human being all of us are different you
might have one different joke you could
talk about your history but good news
you're already different because you're
just a different human being you're also
going to have a listing that somebody
else doesn't have that already Makes You
Different the house is different don't
worry about that part it's it's one of
those silly things that doesn't mean
anything